hey everyone this is feed Master coosto
kutzki here for chess.com and today I'm
going to be doing part two of my series
on Magnus Carlson and today I'm going to
be showing the game against the world
champion unand and this is the game from
the Grand Slam final which was a a super
tournament that took place last October
so Carlson's playing white here and he
opted for this bishop B5 checkline which
isn't considered so dangerous for black
compared to some sharper lines in the
Sicilian but after C4 we can see
Carlson's point and this has of course
been played many times before and that
white is trying to establish a space
advantage in the center by setting up
this kind of morazzi bind structure with
pawns on e4 and C4 and next he's going
to play D4 of course so Knight F6 Knight
C3 G6 D4 this opening isn't considered
so dangerous for black compared to the
stand morazzi bind because black has
already traded off the light scored
Bishops which means that by trading off
a pair of minor pieces their position
isn't going to be so cramped and lacking
space and generally black has done just
fine in this opening but as we already
know I talked a bit about this in the
previous video Carlson doesn't really
aim to get some kind of serious
Advantage from the opening he just wants
to get a normal playable position where
he can try different ideas and try it an
out play his opponent in the middle game
and and often in the end game as well so
here Anan plays Queen C7 this is kind of
a rare move but the point is that after
B3 and queen A5 Bishop B2 black has
forced this bishop to B2 which is seems
like a good square but a lot of times
this bishop would rather be on E3 and
Black's Queen on A5 is quite normally
placed black plays Knight C6 castles
castles Knight C2 Carlson Maneuvers this
Knight to E2 anticipating the trade of
these Knights here so he can recapture
with his Knight on D4 Anan plays rook d8
and he's preparing to play D5 at some
point either with the help of E6 or just
straight up as happened in the game
Bishop C3 Queen B6 King H1 and now D5 so
this is an excellent move by the world
champion black is fighting back against
white space and after this move isn't
left with much of a space to dis
Advantage the point is that after either
of these pawns capture on D5 black can
play Knight takes D5 temporarily
sacrificing the piece white recaptures
black takes back the rook and there's no
way to defend this Knight on D4 and in
fact black is probably going to be
better here after they win back their
piece on D4 their pieces are going to be
slightly more active so Carlson plays
the only move here which is Knight takes
C6 BC and now he finds a very strong
move Queen E1 so he gets his Queen away
from the discovered attack from Black's
rook and sets up a threat of his own
Bishop A5 winning the exchange and here
Anan plays Rook dc8 which I think is
definitely inaccurate probably A5 would
have been better here for a reason I'll
explain in just a sec so after Rook dc8
Carlson plays E5 Anand would like to
play Knight D7 but the problem is
Carlson has this Pawn sacrifice E6 and
this sacrifice was also seen in the game
in a slightly different scenario and
it's quite good here for white with the
Knight and D7 black would like to play
D4 avoiding the trade of Bishops and
keeping their strong dark scirt Bishop
but after e takes D7 white hits The Rook
with Tempo and black is losing a lot of
material of course this wouldn't be the
case if the Rook was on d8 and Black's
Pawn was on A5 in this case black would
have the move Knight D7 available and
white wouldn't be able to do any of this
so for instance here after A5 E5 Knight
D7 E6 black can play D4 pretty
comfortably and if white takes on D7
well black is left with this very strong
Dark Sword bishop and is probably doing
pretty well so Rook dc8 was played E5
and now Anan was forced to play Knight
d8 to avoid this line with E6 but
Carlson just plays E6 anyways and this
is a really really strong Pawn sacrifice
and the point is that white just gives
black this weakness on E6 which he can
attack with Knight F4 and these double
pawns on the E file are very hard to
play around with Black's major pieces
and Black's pieces for the rest of the
game are fairly uncoordinated and this
lack of coordination and lack of Harmony
in Black's position leads to Carlson's
Victory so after Knight F4 an Nan took
on C3 Queen takes C3 he played D4 Queen
D2 and C5 defending the pawn Rook ae1
Knight G7
and here Carlson played the move G4 so
Carlson isn't trying to win back his
Pawn he's strictly playing for
compensation black is going to be up a
pawn here but the problem is that all of
Black's pieces are really poorly placed
and again these doubled pawns are
definitely restricting all of Black's
pieces not how there's really no way for
Black's Rooks or queen to get active
here and here Anan made a really serious
mistake and possibly the losing move he
played the move Rook C6 here this move
is very logical he puts this Rook
defending his weakness on E6 and gets
ready to play his other Rook to the file
but after Carlson's next move Knight H3
suddenly we realize that black has no
good defense to the threat of Queen H6
and Knight G5 and suddenly White's
attack becomes very very strong so Anan
played Knight E8 Queen H6 Knight F6
Knight G5 Black's pieces here are
basically
passive and can't really do much and you
know this is where Carlson shines if you
give him the initiative a lot of times
he doesn't let you off the hook in fact
almost never a nan here tried
D3 trying to distract the white pieces
and hopefully activate his own pieces
along the D file and here Carlson finds
a brilliant move that more or less ends
the game he plays Rook
E5 so the threat of this move is to play
Knight takes H7 followed by Queen takes
takes G6 and bringing the rook in with a
devastating attack so for instance Rook
d8 Knight takes H7 takes
check King h8 Rook H5 is game over king
f8 queen takes and White's even up a
pawn here The Rook is coming to G5 you
know black can basically resign and
again look at the position of Black's
pieces the queen and the Rook are doing
absolutely nothing and just can't
contribute to the defense so because
because of the threat of Knight takes H7
black was forced to play King h8 but now
there is no way to play any of his
pieces to the D6 or d8 scores because of
kn9 F7 check winning material and
because of this Carlson simply plays
Rook D1 threatening to take the pawn
black has no way to defend it again
because of Knight F7 check so Anan
played Queen
A6 A4 and here Anan simply
resigned he resigned here because even
though he's up a pawn his pieces have no
activity and White's play here is
extremely simple he's just going to take
this pawn and then play either Rook E3
and take this Pawn or play something
like H4 and H5 and open up the black
king and win the game and basically
black has absolutely no defense here no
way to stop any of these many threats so
quite a dominating game by Magnus
Carlson I mean it's not every day you
see the world champion lose in 30 moves
you know in such a devastating ating
fashion and the critical point of course
was here after G4 restricting Black's
Knight Carlson set up this deadly threat
of Knight H3 and after the move Rook C6
Knight H3 the game is basically over and
there was nothing that Anan could have
done to stop Carlson's devastating
attack and this move Rook E5 really
sealed the deal
here after King h8 Rook D1 Queen A6 and
A4 and I didn't see any defense to Rook
D3 Rook E3 H4 H5 and simply thrw in the
towel thanks a lot for listening and
I'll see you around on chess.com